you know in another lifetime you and I
would have made a hot ass couple
agreed where's hold you told me to come
in here yeah that was me I've been
recording his voice for the past two
years and now I have a soundboard where
I can make him say anything I want check
it out Diaz I need to see you in the
briefing room now pretty cool right
watch this milk milk lemonade around the
corner fudge is made that is amazing
isn't it what do you want to find do you
love come on check it out Den 34 the
only female traitor pass Finance people
the worst okay we'll take a gander
Jessica professional stunt woman just
back from a surf trip in Bali people who
surf never shut up about it kind of true
you know who doesn't serve Gabrielle I'm
out come on Rosa just give me a shot if
I mess it up fine I'll drop it and I'll
never bring it up again fine one date
that's all you get that's all I need hey
Diaz enjoy having sexual fun with
linet's lesbian friend get
get oh wow that was really really sweet
oh dip I got Rosa to feel her feelings
too inadvertent Gina moment two for one
come in my babies come in sorry to
interrupt ladies but you might want to
take a couple of steps back this is not
going to smell
good Gina since you're leaving I'd like
to make a toast
bye oh my God that was perfect so
nice wait a
minute I think I just figured something
out I got to go aren't you forgetting
something
uh no pay your bill damn who raised you
hey got an arrest file here for the
captain drunk and disorderly so anyways
Gina we never talk anymore how's the
dance troop did you get a haircut what's
the captain schedule like today I'm not
going to help you rob him Jake I'm his
assistant and I take that job incredibly
seriously you're literally making paper
airplanes out of police reports right
now well how am I supposed to get it
into that garbage Camp come on fine
Captain's got a meeting downstairs in 10
minutes you're the
best what does your skin taste like Dina
Lohan I'm wearing her face lotion that's
it so hit me how much do I have to back
in order to keep this place Infinity
perc technically speaking you're
bankrupt kiddo that sounds bad it is bad
I only said Kiddo to sof in the blow
kiddo
wow never thought I'd live to see Holt
side with a vulture and lch mark the day
Gina May 18th at 400 p.m. oh honey we're
well into October really Gina big news
Terry's friend got back to us and he
says they're doing security for Bayside
highs number one wrestler AC Slater
that's right Mario Lopez oh my God I had
such a big crush on him yeah we all had
a big crush on AC Slater get in
line I'll be cooler when we meet him I
should hope so anyways he's hanging out
at the Manhattan Club right now we can
go there and try and talk to him Jak you
can't just walk into the Manhattan Club
it's very exclusive like how exclusive
are we talking here jeans no jeans more
no poor people of any kind no matter how
well they hide it just a tiny slice of
the super rich is it all Illuminati is
it just a whole room full of lizards
Bingo well then I guess we'll have to
transform our
into the uber
[Applause]
wealthy Charles turn that music off oh
sorry I was just pring in case you guys
changed your mind Hey should we take
odds on how fast I'll solve this case n
i mean what was it with Diaz's last
impossible extortion case what was it 6
hours that's because it was 98% Sol
the last 2% hardest to get that's why
they leave it in the milk what I hate
the vulture so much me too bud he is
kind of
hot what you can hate people and still
think they're hot case in point Manuel
Nora you know what I'm with you on this
Tanya Harding yeah she's thick okay
guess I don't have a lot of time I need
your full signed confession we have 4
minutes we can do this but I'm not
guilty listen to me Gus
we can do this
son yo is this a police station or a
toilet cuz all I see is
turds ATT the
pen oh no I spilled coffee on you by
accident lucky for you this wipes off
quickly it's Coast made out a whel skin
the vulture still flies the vulture
still
[Music]
flies hey P what do you say we go talk
about a case in the break room I am what
case is that a case of how you got got
so damn sexy god owee me a favor K hey
dum dum what are you thinking
introducing Amy to her celebrity crush
are you insane relax Charles it's not a
crush it's her nerdy crossw puzzling
hero I mean the guy's got to be a
massive dork his name is Melvin stermley
for God's sake Jake he's here come meet
Melvin hey you can call me
vin but where is nerd so here are your
puzzles from the daisy arsena set the
fires this is really good Amy thanks hey
so Vin uh just curious would you say you
have the typical physique of a puzzle
maker or well each puzzle only pays a
couple hundred bucks so I mostly make my
money modeling it primarily swimwear
yeah I hear that I could do that too but
I make pretty good money here so I don't
really need to anyways let's talk about
the case so here's a letter that the
arsonist sent to then your Clues I just
combobulate to teach you to conjugate
the fool who fails to validate will
watch as I congrate it seems like he
using my cross word to tell me something
oh maybe we should look at anagrams of
the answers that's really good old nasty
Amiga oh what he rearranged the letters
of Amy Santiago he anagrammed me Benin
do Jake Peralta I doubt that's even
possible eat a jerk pal what no one's
ever said that phrase I really think
this anagram approach makes a lot of
sense seriously let's do it I'll take
even Clues you take odds great and I
will take everyone's coffee order that's
equally helpful I don't drink coffee but
I love a kombucha great I'll just walk
to the kombucha store everything okay
yeah of course you can't wear a coat
over a tank you're not Ryan goling
feeling jealous buddy no not at all I
mean I am a little surprised that
somebody named Melvin is so Bodacious
but I feel that jealousy is an ugly
emotion hey you're feeling and I'm just
glad that Amy is spending some time with
her hero who is super hot Charles Let It
Go and smart I'm serious
stop and hilarious eat a jerk pal so
how's it going in here V I see you're
still coatless I run hot like a wolf oh
I see I wonder if the word conjugate in
the arsonist letter means we should
focus on the verb answers cool I love
verbs second favorite part of speech
after yeah words are cool but maybe we
should switch gears a bit and get back
to some good oldfashioned police work
what are you thinking well whoever
setting these fires is clearly trying to
humiliate Finn you know make a puzzle he
can't solve so maybe we should focus on
people that don't like you Jake has a
point about motive maybe another Puzzler
wants to take you down well if you're
looking for a puzzle head I'm hosting a
crossroad night at the turnkey bar
tonight oh I've always wanted to go
there that place is a total puz hang
gross all right so we'll go undercover
chat some people up and see if we can't
find our arsonist good idea oh Emy likes
my plan great so Vin why don't we just
get this coat back on you and I'll help
you get out of the door here and we'll
see you tonight okay
bye the best right yeah I'd like to
introduce you to your new assistant drum
roll
please that's your drum roll when a
Tempo isn't specified any reasonable
person but default tento well it's
terrible and you ruined a fun thing but
I would still like to introduce you to
Mr Gordon
Lunt Mr Gordon
Lunt Gordon you want to come in here oh
I'm so sorry I was just deciding whether
I should just go home the tone and tener
of your introduction make me worry that
this is a fun office which I would not
enjoy hello I'm captain Raymond hold and
I can assure you this is not a fun
office thank goodness in that case my
interest is renewed here is my resume
I'm feeling this are you guys feeling
this Gordon why don't you tell Captain
Holt a little bit about yourself where
again I'm 174 cm tall I can type 103
words per minute with an error rate of
1.6% and I recently moved here from
Philadelphia which is a sixth most
populous US city I understand the city
of Philadelphia is co-terminus with
Philadelphia County making it the eighth
largest metropolitan statistical area
yeah Philly's cool isn't it fun just
telling each other facts yes well I
think I have all the information I need
thank you for coming in Mr L my
pleasure so looks like operation nasty
is a full-on success huh you mean
operation nasty sex lot who was it was
about night with did you see him
flirting with me no I most definitely
did not and you're a blind man and
approved to boot did you see his tie a
single Windsor the easiest not to undo
why bother wearing any clothes at all I
think you badly misread that interaction
please he did everything but lick his
lips and purr get rid of them and bring
me someone who can keep it in their
slacks the plan was for me to weaken
your defenses of my Brazen sexuality I
wouldn't say Brazen so much is
completely undetectable I couldn't have
been more obvious I wore single WIS or
not I might as well have a sign on my
neck that reads DTF Desiring thorough
fornication Noe exactly oh thanks for
doing that Teddy I'm really glad that we
could be friends again of course I'll
always be here for you which is why I
have a question to ask oh man May me
Santiago will
you